So glad to have you all here i'm not
really allowed to share anything so
i'm going to hand it over to the great
matt reeves somewhere around here
your heart starts pumping interacting with
the passionate fan base ready okay let's go
the batmobile is no joke you are so good
looking it's a completely different experience
i'm dropping the mic
dc fandome hall of heroes all fans welcome
24 hours only and there's only one place
you can experience it at dc fandome.com
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
dc fandome trailer video they just announced that
they're doing another fandome event this year
in october so we'll break it all down obviously
they're going to be hyping up all the big upcoming
movies some of the video games and all the hbo tv
shows that they're doing if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get everything
there's gonna be a bunch more dc stuff happening
this year and obviously next year too because we
have all the batman stuff that's happening i think
the idea is that things went so well last year
because they couldn't do a big comic con hall age
panel and it's kind of a similar situation this
year even though technically comic-con san diego
comic-con the official one is trying to do an
event in november on thanksgiving weekend if you
really want to feel free to roll the dice on that
kind of close quarters in person type of event
this soon i have a feeling it'll probably be next
year before we go back to really big in-person
conventions this year's dc fandom event will be
a little bit different in that a few of the movies
that they were hyping up at last year's event have
already come out or will have come out by the time
it happens like they won't be showing off wonder
woman stuff they won't be hyping up wonder woman
1984 maybe they'll announce wonder woman 3 in the
suicide squad movie will have already come out
a couple months previously that's being released
in august this event is happening in october so
the main focus will be on showing footage for the
upcoming stuff in future movies starting obviously
with the batman movie that's probably going to be
the crown jewel of this year's fandom again it
was kind of the same situation with last year's
fandom as well and since it's been a hot minute
since we've all seen movies in theaters october
is typically the month when you start seeing the
big trailers for the upcoming spring movies the
next year but the really cool thing is the batman
movie is coming out in march so it's actually a
little bit sooner you don't have to wait till
may or june of next year matt reeves did that
huge batman panel at last year's fandom showing
off the first trailer at the time they were still
planning on releasing that movie october 2021 so
it's funny how this ended up working out they'll
be showing another major trailer around the time
we were supposed to have been watching the movie
and if you go back far enough originally the
batman movie was supposed to come out june 2021
before the first delay happened but the batman
movie will probably just be the biggest thing that
they're doing there because robert pattinson's
being positioned as the new main version of batman
in the dc movies ben affleck is coming back
for the flash movie as his version of batman
which they actually just started production on
and michael keaton himself also just traveled
to the set to start filming his scenes as his
version of batman from the tim burton movies
they'll also probably use dc fandom this year
to release the first official teaser trailer for
the flash movie because even if they're not done
they'll be almost done filming the movie by then
and matt reeves was able to drop that batman
trailer last year after only a couple weeks
of filming i think part of the whole idea too
is that they really want to hype up michael
keaton coming back as batman so they want to
show a trailer for the flash movie off where
he's actually wearing a batman costume and ezra
miller is wearing his new flash costume like see
see we have all the batman's the whole thing
with robert pattinson becoming the main version
of batman though ben affleck's batman is meant to
be a smaller part of the movie than michael keaton
and for the most part the way they've talked
about the future of michael keaton's batman he's
not gonna be the main version of batman in the dc
universe even though it kind of sounds like he is
like the way he's envisioned is a big crossover
batman for other future movies like they want
to sign michael keaton to a multiple film deal
so that he comes back in other people's movies
as well the whole reason for doing it that way
though is obviously it's a really cool idea to
bring michael keaton's batman back for hopefully
batman beyond in the future but matt reeves wanted
his robert pattinson batman movies potential
sequels obviously if things go well to take place
on a different earth so they didn't have to
worry about all the pre-existing justice league
continuity like he just wanted to make a very
self-contained batman movie and didn't want to
deal with all the stuff that's happened before so
that's why he's saying that the batman movie is
an earth 2 movie and the justice league snyder
cut version of earth with all those versions
of the characters like ben affleck's batman is
meant to take place on earth prime in the dc
multiverse the main version of earth it sounds
more complicated than it is they just want each
of the new directors that are coming on for the
upcoming dc movies to be able to do just whatever
they want to do with the characters without having
to worry about too much pre-existing continuity so
matt reeves way of simplifying all the potential
continuity issues with introducing a new younger
version of batman way younger version but having
the movie take place in present day is just to say
that it's happening in a different universe so if
it wasn't clear from the first batman trailer the
robber pattinson batman movie actually takes
place pretty close to present day like there
were smartphones that were spotted in scenes when
they were filming and this lincoln navigator that
the riddler is crashing into the mayor's funeral
during this trailer scene is a late model from
the last couple of years and because the justice
league snyder cut is also taking place mostly in
present day not including the nightmare ending
scene with the flash forward the joker scene all
the alternate timelines and the time travel that
they reference it just creates a lot of potential
continuity issues with the way you explain this
new version of batman showing up robert pattinson
so the director of the flash movie separately
said that a lot of what they're doing with the
flash character in the multiverse will help tie
all these different movie franchises together in
a much clearer way but i think if you've ever
read any multiverse story from dc comics or
you've watched any of the dc tv shows the past few
years like the crisis on infinite earth's episodes
you already have a pretty good understanding of
how the dc multiverse works like if you include
the version of batman that they have on the titans
tv show now they have four different versions
of live action batman flying around just live
action not including any of the animated movies
marvel is just now getting into that concept
of the multiverse and their movies in the
disney plus series with stuff like the loki series
that's coming up that i'll be doing episodes for
and doctor strange too which is literally titled
multiverse of madness so both marvel and dc are
rolling hard on the multiverse in the next five
years the other big trailers and previews we'll
probably be seeing at this new dc fandom will be
for the john cena suicide squad hbo tv series that
james gunn is still in the middle of filming right
now you probably seen him posting a lot about that
recently the dc hbo series are going to be dc's
version of the marvel disney plus series exact
same concept with all the movie actors crossing
over but the suicide squad hbo tv series is just
going to be called peacemaker because john cena's
character is the main character and it's supposed
to release episodes starting january 2022. if
you remember the one division episodes starting
in january this past year it'll be the exact
same situation with the peacemaker stuff on hbo
matt reeves is also making that batman hbo series
spin-off from the batman movie i don't know if
we're gonna see a preview for that at dc fandom
they'll probably mostly be focusing on the batman
movie itself but the whole idea is the movie is
meant to be batman year two like he's a brand new
batman but it's not batman year one but they will
be doing batman year one stuff during the batman
hbo series it's gonna take place a year before the
events in the batman film they've confirmed that
gordon is supposed to be the main character and
it's not gonna be a gotham city central tv show
matt reeves was very clear about that like no
we're not doing gotham city central they will
be doing more stuff with the movie characters
but they haven't confirmed which other movie
characters will show up like there'll be some
batman stuff happening but i think more of a focus
on his rogues gallery of villains but i think
the whole idea is that they're going to have a
trilogy of new batman movies with robert pattinson
if everything goes well and whatever happens with
the batman hbo series it'll just weave in with the
timeline of those sequels i don't think the batman
hbo series is supposed to release till later
in 2022 then we'll also probably get our first
official preview of the green lantern hbo
tv series they've already confirmed that
it's going to be about alan scott guy gardner
sinestro killwog jessica cruz simon baz and then
an original character that we just found out about
called brie jarda there have been a lot of casting
sides and dialogue that has leaked out but i
don't think that that stuff is going to wind up in
the actual show they just use that stuff for the
casting process for those of you asking what about
how jordan and john stewart i think the whole idea
is that they're going to introduce versions of
those characters in a new green lantern core movie
that they're still working on but they haven't
said much about recently you may remember zack
snyder was talking about them making him delete
his green lantern scene at the end of the justice
league snyder cut so you all probably watched the
justice league snyder cut you remember that in
credit scene where you have martian manhunter
coming to batman's lake house to introduce himself
and officially announced that he was going to help
them in the future a couple weeks ago zack snyder
revealed that he had actually filmed a green
lantern scene that was meant to take place during
this scene but he replaced it with the martian
manhunter scene because the studio asked him to
delete it what was going to happen is that he was
going to have a version of killwag show up with
a version of jon stewart did he cast this is who
the actor was this is what it was going to look
like but when the studio saw his green lantern
scene like he gave him the cut of the movie they
said you have to get rid of this you can't use jon
stewart in this scene he didn't explain why they
made him get rid of it but i think the idea is
they want to introduce their own version of jon
stewart separately in a different movie that's
coming up in the next couple of years if you're a
big fan of the video games too they also use the
dc fandome event to hype up the video games
i think they'll show off some more gotham
night stuff but i also believe that they might
wind up announcing injustice 3 because i think
it was actually announced a while ago that the
studio was working on a sequel to injustice 2.
but whatever ends up happening whatever footage
they drop of course i'll do videos about it
everyone leave all your big questions and your
video requests in the comments below for any dc
stuff that you want me to make videos about you
can click here for my mortal kombat movie ending
and end credit scene video and click here for my
brand new captain america 4 movie announcement
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!